closed off to the world
gaza is being bombed into submission
[Music]
inside the coastal enclave people living
here describe it as a prison
it's a scene of daily terror and horror
this is the story of 11 girls killed
over the last week by israeli air
strikes
we know about them because they were
being treated for trauma
and severe anxiety by the norwegian
refugee council
after years of war amongst them
were sisters yara who was nine and ruler
she was just five
they died along with twelve members of
their family
this is what's left of their home
the damage in gaza after many rounds of
fighting
is extensive the strip has been under an
economic and military blockade
by israel and egypt since 2007.
israel says the blockade is to prevent
hamas
designated a terror organization by much
of the world
from doing this firing rockets into
civilian areas
inside israel terrorizing the country's
population
and under increasing international
pressure prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
told a meeting of foreign diplomats the
idf is doing
everything it can to avoid civilian
casualties
we go to unprecedented lands to prevent
civilian casualties
when you see those buildings that fall
there's not a single
civilian death there there are probably
children there
so we're not going to do it
but the young are dying and being
injured
a constant stream of children 61 have
been killed so far
are brought into the al schiffer
hospital but the care they get is basic
medical supplies like everything here is
running out
israel says it is determined to restore
calm
and impose a lasting deterrent but the
cause for a ceasefire
are growing louder with the us hardening
its tone
but whilst the diplomacy drags on it's
those caught in the fighting
that continue to suffer alex rossi
sky news jerusalem